[Applaudissements]
bon sang je me fais nantes et toi avec
ton 3 toi derrière ton truc de dingue ce
que je suis en train de vivre
j'ai 34 ans je m'en fou non owen quoique
ischia ont construit une tiana 3
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors allez-y terminé ton grand talent
je sors puisque tous les soirs 2000 moi
j'ai une émission de radio tous les
soirs on trouve un de ces jeunes qui se
met c'est drôle moi ça ne me fait peur
je suis comme guy ce n'est pas
divertissant
j'y ferai ce match aller défendre qu'un
petit con comme toi qui est des fonds
généraux et aux oscars est ce que tu as
dit c'est le par les organes des
familles si des cellules marley et nohra
elles sont les boulettes
[Musique]
ohlala oh là là et laura ça va mais
bordel tu te calmes tantôt calme j'ai
très très peur
les années sont coincés dépendra de nous
ça c'est parfait ouais bien pâle ou
c'est beau
là